Of course work and
understanding how the brain processes
visual information continues.
One of the interesting things has been,
sort of, separating out the, there
seems to be work in, in, understanding
that the layout of your visual field,
the geometry of your field is different
than understanding what's in your
field that is the, the,
detection of things.
And so notionally here,
here's an interesting little picture.
The idea is that things come in, in V1
and then V2 starts to go up this area.
This is the V3, V4 subsegment that
sort of does the recognition.
This is sort of what's there.
At the same time, there seems to be
what's referred to as this action
pathway where V1 has a lot of
projections into this V3 V5 area
that's sensitive to, it is sensitive
to shape, but the movements of shapes.
And then there's always connections,
cause there's connections
everywhere in the brain.
But the idea is that
in the parietal lobes,
that's a different structure up here,
is more of an understanding of action.
So you have this one pathway that's
sort of the stuff that's there, and
another one that has to do with
sort of how stuff's moving,
or, or where stuff is moving.
There's another whole cool area of,
another cool way of investigating
what goes on in the brain.
If you presume that there are these
different kinds of process steps
going on in different locations, then
you would expect that people who have
certain types of brain injuries or,
or birth defect issues or
whatever, that certain parts of
the brain aren't working You would be
able to find selective elements of
their visual processing not function.
We know this is true in language.
Strokes in different areas can cause you
to lose either semantics versus syntax.
So what happens in vision?
Well, there's this
very well known woman.
She has this very interesting phenomena,
she cannot see motion.
So like, she can't cross a street.
She'll look down there and
she'll see the car there.
And then, you know, two seconds later,
she'll see the car here.
But she has no perception that
the car is actually moving.
'Kay, so
she can't actually cross the street.
All right?
Because she doesn't get any
understanding of sort of that
space time evolution of things.
So that, you can think of that as
an example of there's this part that's
doing this motion and action stuff that,
in her brain, is just not working.
Remember she recognizes cars and
toothpaste and all the different
kinds of things in her world.
But she doesn't get a perception
of the motion and the action.
And this is the type of thing that
leads further credence to the idea that
there's a separate pathway, this,
this separate part of the brain that is
processing this kind of information
that obviously she doesn't have.
So, the idea would be that you know
this action pathway shown here Somehow
is not functioning as well as
it should in her, in her brain.